[Alkış]
Merhabalar
sizin de bir iç sesiniz var mı
hatırlar mısınız
Pinokyo'nun bir çekirgesi var hatırlıyor
musunuz Çekirge
öyle zor zamanlarda
Pinokyo kötü bir şey yapacağız ama bir
hata yapacağız ama
hemen ve ona derdi ki
tanımaya çalışırdı
Etiler
şurada konuşuyordum ya
o konuşan Aslında ben değilim
benim Çekirge
Lütfen şimdi bana öyle bakmayın
gidiyorum sanıyorsunuz sizin de var
diğer cümleyi teklifiniz hem de her gün
bizim
Mesela az önce buraya gelmeden yolda
böyle kavgacı biriyle karşılaştıysanız
hemen Eğer şimdi size demiştir kişi
Tamam boş ver
takılma başım belaya sokma Şimdi
demiştir sizi korumaya çalışmıştır ya da
az sonra eğer sağlık noktasında öksürük
tutsaksa denize yine gelecek
size
Nezaket kurallarını hatırlatacak
sessiz öksürsünüz şimdi bak kadın
konuşuyor sahnede Dikkatimi dağıtma
diyeceksin size
kendince sizi korumaya çalışacak
biraz rahatsız edecek Belki biraz Susam
duracak Ama en çok da ne yapmaya
çalışacak biliyor musunuz başkalarının
Sizin hakkınızda kötü şeyler düşünmesini
engellemeye çalışacak
bizim jimin içeceklerimiz bizim iç
sesimiz
bir Doğduğumuzda yoktu ama sonra bir
baktık ki
bizimle birlikte
omzumuzda zihnimizde
dikkat et
Dikkat et kendine güvenli görün
abartmadan konuş güler yüzlü ol
Saçmalama hata yapma sözlerini unutma
bu sürekli beni tetikte tutan beni
bitirdi rahat bırakmayan şu anda tam da
şu sırada şu sahnenin tadını çıkarmaya
başladığım anlarda
sürekli konuşan ses Bu gerçekten benim
kendi iç sesimi
kontrollü ol sakın hata yapma
sakın insanların gözünün içine bak Dik
Dur biraz karnını da içeri doğru çek bir
düşünün bakalım sizin iç sesiniz size en
çok hangi türden cümleler söylüyor
mesela Mesela şöyle diyelim el ile akşam
Kapı çaldı arkadaşınız habersiz bir
şekilde size geldi
Kesinlikle kötü bir şey oldu Dur dur bir
dakika ne olduğunu sorma belki anlatmak
istemiyordur Sen en iyisisin
onu da sorma hemen güzel sevdiği bir
şeyler hazırlar arkadaşlar
diyelim ki Çocuğunuz keyifli bir şekilde
koridorda oradan oraya zıplamaya başladı
Söyle ona düşecek düşecek Şimdi kafasını
patlatacak hastanede olacaksınız ya da
çok sevdiğiniz biri yani size ne kadar
Çalışkan Azimli başarılı bir olduğunuzu
anlatmaya başladı
çekirgenizin orada mı yine orada mısın
Tamam Hadi konuyu değiştir daha övgüler
yaptırıyor da zaten bir kısmı abartı ve
alçak gönüllü ol
İnsan bir Gülümse bozuldu bu ama
değiştir konuyu
yok Yok ya
bu ses benden geliyor olamaz Peki
nereden geliyor Bu iç ses Hadi yeni
şöyle biraz geriye doğru gidelim
şu hayatta bize çok yakın olmuş bizi de
sıklıkla böyle konuşmuş
Neyi öğretmiş biri olmalı Kim o
Tabii ki annemiz
bazılarımız için baba ya da anne ile
baba ile büyüyemeyenler için onlardan
sonra bize çok yakın olmuş bize bakım
vermiş kişiler
biliyor musunuz Ben çok uzun yıllar
boyunca
zihnimde annemin iç sesiyle yaşadım
Evet nereye gitsem benimle geliyordu hep
omzumdaydı zihindeydi annemden Bana
kalan o iç sesle birlikte yaşıyorum
olsun canım arkadaşım evime gelmiş karnı
aç ben de kendimi para alıyorum böyle
onu sevdiği bir yemekleri hazırlamaya
çalışıyorum bu evi düzelsin diye
karıştırıyorum Gerçi böyle yaptığım
zamanlarda arkadaşım genelde Şöyle bir
tepki veriyor bana yani Yasuo ya
ya da çocuğum oradan oraya zıplarken
Yavrum bunu ona dikkat et biraz düşme
falan derken o da yine gözlerini
deviriyor ve bana ya diyor
biliyor musunuz Böyle zamanlarda ben
bile
Hani bir söz vardır ya benim sesim
çocuğuma sinek vızıltısı gibi gelir diye
İnanır mısınız böyle zamanlarda
Benim sesim kendime bile sinek vızıltısı
gibi geliyor Bu arada çocuğun koşmaya
zıplamaya devam ediyor
tabi doğal bu
çocuk doğada yaşıyor Peki annesi Ben ben
Doğan mıyım
doğal mı davranıyorum ben
Ah ah bana onun kalbini açan kişi güzel
sözler söyleyen kişi var ya Biliyor
musunuz bazen O sözleri duyduğumda
bilmiyorum ama
bunların doğru olduğuna inanamıyorum
Kendimi o anın büyüsüne teslim
edemiyorum
Neden böyleyim
acaba başkaları mutlu olsun başkaları
kendini iyi hissetsin diye sürekli
kendini paralayan bu ben miyim ya da
sürekli Gerçekçi olmayan hisleri gören
o ağrın büyüsü de kapılamayan seçtiğim
olamayan bu
yoksa
yoksa annemin iç sesi bazen yaşamamak
engel mi oluyor böyle hayatın tadında
çıkarmama engel mi oluyor yoksa annemin
iç sesi bana bir şeyler mi sürekli bana
[Müzik]
başkalarını güvenli hissettirmezsen
başkalarının mutlu etmezsen Bu iyi bir
şey değil Çünkü başkalarının mutlu
olması
Bundan daha önemli mi diyor yoksa
annemden bana Miras kalan o ilk ses Eğer
böyle yapmazsan
yalnız kalırsın kimse seni sevmez mi
diyor
ne olur arkadaşım evime geç gelse ve ben
dolabın kapağını açsam ona keyfine bak
dostum desem ne olur çocuğum Neyse
oynarken ona hiç müdahale etmesem ve ne
olur o güzel sözleri söyleyen kişiye
inansan güvensem sözleri abartı bile
olsa söylediği güzel şeyler yalan bile
olsa
zihinini yine mi geldin bir git lütfen
Git söylediği o güzel sözleri tadını
çıkarsam O anın büyüsüne kapılsam
bıraksam
hatırlar mısınız
kirlenmek güzeldir diyordu Bir deterjan
reklamında
kirlenmek güzeldir ama
farkında mısınız iç sesimiz dikkat et
kirleneceksin diyor sürekli işsizim
istila benim güzel olduğumu biliyor mu
acaba
Belli ki bilmiyor
Ben biliyorum
Mesleğimi ikna ettiğim bunca yıl boyunca
ne fark ettim biliyor musunuz yaklaşık
17-18 senedir terapistlik yapıyorum ben
ve
şunu fark ettim
ne zaman ki
kendi Özgün otantik sesini sadece kendi
sesimi terapi odasına dahil ettim ne
zaman ki
danışalım ve kendi Özgün sesin dışında
kimsesi Yeminle dahi Çekirge dahil
hiçbir sesi terapi odasından sokmamayı
başardım İşte o zaman
[Müzik]
Biraz önceki hikayeye geri dönelim
varsayalım ki arkadaşıma bir akşamlık
yiyecek güzel bir şeyler hazırlayamadım
ne olur dünyanın sonu mu gelir
Evet Muhtemelen dünyanın sonunun gelmesi
en düşük ihtimaldir olacak olan şey
arkadaşımın bir akşamlık sevgili bir
şeyleri yememektedir ya da ne olur
çocuğum
koşarken düşse bir yere götürülür
Muhtemelen yanılıyorum olacak olan şey
çok büyük ihtimalle düşmesi biraz canım
acıması sonra kalkması biraz hızlanması
ve onunla devam etmesidir zaten
çocuğum başına gelen bir şeyler de hemen
pes etmesin vazgeçmesin devam etsin
yaşadıklarından öğrensin hata yapsın ve
hata yapmamayı hata yaparak öğrensin
istiyorum İşte bu işe yarayacak çocuğun
böyle öğrenecek
ve
ve ne olur Ben o güzel sözlerin bana
söylenen o güzel iltifatların tadını
çıkarsam
ne olur
Biz mutlu olmayı hak etmiyor muyuz
kirlenmekten korkuyoruz ama kirlenmekten
çok korkuyoruz ama bir taraftan da
hatırlamamız gerekiyor ki
dinlenmekten korkan var mı aranızda
bilmiyorum Bir daha tam da hatırlamamız
gerekiyor ki hata
yapmayı göze almalıyız çünkü
15 güzelse Hata yapmaktan öğreticidir
Eğer kirlenmek güzelse hata yapmak böyle
için Salih
kirlenmeye hata yapmayı göze aldınız mı
Şöyle bir düşünün bakalım
önce şunu konuşalım
hata yaptığımız çocuk yani kirlenmedi
sen daha yaptığın zamanları şöyle bir
gözünüzün önüne getirmeye çalışın O
anlarda anne Babanız size nasıl tepkiler
verirler hatırlıyor musunuz Mesela
kirlendiğinizde nasıl
temizleneceğinize size Öğrettiler mi
hata yaptığınızda hatanızı telafi etmek
için size bir şans daha verdiler mi
yoksa
Yoksa sizi eleştirdiler mi kızdılar mı
sözlü ya da sözsüz sizi yargıladı var mı
gittim sana dikkat et diye Yoksa bunları
mı söylediler
Bakalım eğer içtiyseniz size
hata yaparsınız yanılırsın
çuvallarsın beceremezsin aptalsın
düşersin şaşarsın diyorsan
ki
sizin gerçeğ
iniz
O sizin gerçeğimiz değil Çünkü biz hata
yaptığımızda iç sesimiz bize Anne
babamız gibi davranmaya başlıyor
şimdi lütfen şöyle hayatta çok
kendinizin mutlu hissettiğiniz anlardan
bir kaçırıp Gözünüz önüne getirmeye
çalışın
mesela çocukken babanızın omzunda
koşuştururken aynı zamanda düşme
ihtimalinizde yok muydu
ya da ya da paraşütle Gökyüzüne doğru
uçmaya başlamışken Bir taraftan da
tehlikeli bir şey yaptığınızı Bilmiyor
muydunuz
kahvede keyifle bir şeyler anlatırken
bir anda sözlerinizi unutma ya da
takılıp düşme ihtimaliniz yok mu
evlenirken
evlenirken evliler düşünsün bakalım
biraz evlenirken o mutlus geçecek bir
ömre imzaya atarken
birlikte bir şey olup da boşanma
ihtimaliniz olabileceğini de
hiç sahip olurken
risklerin en
büyük en şahanesini
[Müzik]
Al işte o anlarda değil mi yaşadığımızı
hissettiğimiz gerçekten hayatta
olduğumuz bütün riskleri bilmemize
rağmen o tercihi yaptığımız o anlarda
değil de gerçek yaşamak hisse
bu hatalar Bu riskler bizi hep Elimizi
kolumuzu bağlıyor
yalnız dedim en güzel anlarınız hata
yapmayı göze aldığınız o anlardır
Eğer ki iç sesiniz hata yapmanızı
engellerse Eğer ki iç sesini size
sürekli dikkat et sakın hata yapma derse
ve siz eğer ki o iç sesinizin
söyledikleri de eğer sürekli dinlerseniz
o zaman
çok önemli bir şey kaybedersiniz biliyor
musunuz
yaşam enerjisi Evet yaşam enerjisi çok
kıymetli bir şey birçok psikopatolojinin
Aslında altında yatan bir şey bu Eğer ki
bir insan yaşam enerjisini kaybediyorsa
gerçekten psikolojik sağlığıyla ilgili
de çok önemli bir kayıp yaşıyor demektir
bakın kirlenmek güzeldir Çünkü
bize yaşam enerjisi verir hata yapmak
güzeldir Çünkü çünkü bize yaşam enerjisi
olarak geri döner
denemek Ağlı yaşamak Risk almak güzeldir
Çünkü bize yaşadığımızı hisset
Eğer ki iç sesiniz sizi sürekli
engelliyorsa
kendinizi önceliklendirmek yerine
sürekli başkalarını önceliklendirmenizi
size söylüyorsa o zaman
mikrofonu
çekirdeğimizden o içtesinizden alıp
kendi Özgün otantik sesinize verme
zamanı gelmiştir Peki o zaman başlayalım
mı
Öncelikle
hata Yaptığını kabul eder misin
hata yaptık bir kabul et ya
ele neydi olsam yaptığın iş de bu usta
da olsam hata yapabileceğine kabul etmem
gerekiyor çok kolay değil Çünkü ne zaman
ki hata yapmaya başlarsak ilk Sesini
hemen devreye giriyor ve
hata yapma Neden Çünkü sadece bizi
korumaya çalışıyor Öyle değil mi
hep hep bize de fısıltıyorduk
kendini Başar dikkat et
Eğer ki eğer ki şöyle bir süreliğine
çekirgenizi bir kenara koyup kendi Özgün
sesimize kulak verir misiniz
uyuyacaksınız
size ne diyecek biliyor musunuz kendi
özgürlük otantik sesiniz Hani oyun
oynayalım diyeceksin
Hadi deneyelim
Hadi deneyelim diyecek ya hadi dans
edelim
diyecek nasıl geliyor kulağımıza
heyecanlanıyor musunuz bunları duyarken
hevesleniyor musunuz Evet Aslında orada
İç sesimiz orada bize bunları söylüyor
bir bakayım yapabilirsin diyor yaşam
enerjimi kaybetme diyor bu senin sesin
diyor ve bizim yapmamız gereken şey işte
o derindeki
çocukluğumuzda bizimle olan Sonra yavaş
yavaş bizden uzaklaşmaya başlayan o
otantik sesinize yeniden Kavuşmamız
Çünkü bu bize yaşam enerjisi verecek
[Müzik]
mekanik psikolog olarak iki çocuğumu Ben
geldiğim için işte böyle iyi yetişmeleri
için
desteklemeye çabalıyorum
elimden geleni en iyisini yaptığımız
zannediyorum kendimce ama aslında bir
taraftan da çok iyi biliyorum ki yapmaya
çalıştığım şey
kendi çocukluk yaralarını sarmaktan
başka bir şey değil
onlar için çabalayışımın Aslında çok
büyük bir kısmı kendi çocukluk
yaralarımı sarmaya çalışmak
ama hepimiz yaralanıyoruz
kimin oğlum bir şey daha var o da şu ki
tıpkı sizler gibi Evet bu salondaki
hepiniz gibi Tıpkı benim gibi
şu anda büyümeye çalışan çocuklarımız
gibi hiç bir çocuk almadan
büyüyemez
yer al
şunu da gözden kaçırmayalım
şifalanmak mümkün
şifalanmak mümkün yaralarımıza rağmen
çıkmak için İnanın bana
aile çok ama çok iyi bir yer aile O
zaman çok iyi bir yer
Eğer ki
kendine iyi bir hediye vermek istiyorsan
bilmenisin ki bu hediye Senin kendi iç
sesim olacak bazen
Bazen kendini eleştirebilirsin kendine
baskı yapabilirsin bazen çocuğunu da
engelleyebiliyorsun kendi de
engelleyebiliyorsun bu çok normal bunun
için kendine kızma
kendi Kızma ama Lütfen şunu da hatırlat
şifalanmak için kendi sesine geri dönmen
gerekiyor çünkü kendine verebileceğin en
büyük hediye kendi sesimle yeniden
buluşmaktır yeniden kavuşmaktır kendi
çocuklarımız da içimizdeki kırgın
çocuklarda Hepsinin en çok ihtiyacı olan
şey o yeşil enerjisi dolu iç seslere
bunun içinde yapılabilecek en iyi şey ne
biliyor musunuz şifalanmak için
yapılabilecek en iyi şey ve kendi sesi
ile konuşmak için yapılabilecek en iyi
şey
duygularınla barışmak tüm duygularını
olduğu haliyle reddetmeden ayırmadan bu
güzeldir Bu ikinci duygu bu olumlu bu
olumsuz bunu istiyorum aynı bunu
istemiyorum benek sizin bütün
duygularına Kucak açmak onlara olduğu
haliyle kabul etmek
Çünkü duygularını kabul etmeye
başladığında Hatta
Birazını yapıp duygularını ifade etme
başladığında içindeki
ve şifalanmaya başlayacaksın
içimizdeki kırgın çocuklarında kendi
çocuklarımızın da İnanın bana en çok
ihtiyacı olan şey duygulara Kucak açmak
onları ayırt etmeksizin kabul etmek ve
böylece şifalanmak
Kendinizi de çocuklarınızda
anlamaya çalışırken lütfen sakin olun
sakin sakin dinleyin
sakin bir ebeveyniniz olamadıysa da siz
sakin ve ebeveyn olun kendinize Çünkü bu
Mümkün çünkü
birçok danışalım Çünkü birçoğumuz böyle
iyileşebiliyoruz
dinleyerek sakin kalarak duyguları kabul
ederek yok saymaya yargılamayarak insan
olduğumuzu
Duygulardan yaratıldığınızı kabul ederek
işte böyle sakince yani sadece ve sadece
dingil olarak değil tüm duyguları
kapsayan bir sakinlikte kendimizi
çocuklarımızı
sevdiklerimizi oldukları haliyle kabul
ederek iyileşiyoruz Siz de Eğer
şifalanmak isterseniz En çok da buna
yapmak isterseniz lütfen sakin kalmaya
çalışın duygularınıza kucak açın ve eğer
bir an gelip de
kendi Kendinizden uzaklaşmak uzaklaşmış
hissederseniz bir an birlikte kendi
Kendinizden uzaklaşmış hissedersiniz
yine çekirgenin güzel Biricik kıymetli
çekirgenizi etkisi altında kaldığınızı
hissederseniz lütfen
Kendinize iyi bakın
Özgün otantik sana ait olan sesini
duyuyor musun
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]